the Navy Times reports the head of the  Navy SEALs is reviewing allegations of  war crimes and drug abuse within the  elite force Rear Admiral Colin green  said yesterday a 90-day review is  underway to look at leadership  development and combat ethics the review  comes nearly two years after a CBS News  investigation exposed drug use among the  Navy SEALs the CBS report also revealed  a video in which a SEAL commander  addressed the drug problem in their  ranks David Martin spoke exclusively  with Navy SEALs who disguised their  identities about the issue for the first  time people that we know of that we hear  about have tested positive for cocaine  methamphetamine heroin marijuana ecstasy  that's a problem how prevalent is drug  abuse in the SEAL Teams it's growing the  drug use it's growing Rear Admiral green  said the review will include part  discussions